[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: So to start,
tell us a little bit
about your background and
how you got into cooking.
MELISSA KING: Let's see.
Well, first off I want to say
thank you guys for having me
here.
I love seeing all the strong,
powerful women out here.
A big girl group here at Google.
So how did I start
off with cooking?
I've been cooking
since I was a kid.
Yeah, I think I was maybe five
or six and helping out my mom.
Both my parents are
engineers, and they're just
working all the time.
And someone had to put food on
the table, so by the age of 12
I was doing that.
And then went to college, got my
undergrad in cognitive science
at UC Irvine.
But I wanted to cook my
whole life since I was young,
and finally I made my way to
culinary school in New York.
And then I've been in San
Francisco since cooking.
SPEAKER: Awesome.
What made you take that step
into cooking from leaving--
from what you were studying?
MELISSA KING: I think
just because that's
what I had known I'd
wanted to do my whole life,
but I felt a little
suppressed by my family.
I grew up in a really
traditional household.
I'm sure many people can
feel that, or relate to that,
with having parents that expect
you to be something else.
And they're like, are you
sure you want to be a chef?
That's just a lot of work,
and you're sweating all day,
and you're in a
kitchen long hours.
You're working every
holiday, every weekend.
But I loved it that much.
And I was like, you know what?
This is what I want
to do with my life,
and I'm going to do it.
And so I kind of did
schooling to please my family,
but eventually kind of went
off and did my own thing.
SPEAKER: So as you welcomed
all the women engineers here--
MELISSA KING: And the men.
SPEAKER: And the men, yeah.
So you faced a lot
of struggles coming
with the traditional
family and all that.
And there's not a
giant percentage
of women culinary master
chefs and all that, and also
part of the LGBTQ community.
What other challenges did
you have going through that,
and what challenges
do you see for others?
MELISSA KING: You
know, I started out
in the industry I'd
say 15 years ago.
And at the time there really
weren't many female chefs
in the media.
There weren't many in kitchens.
I was one of the only
girls for a very long time.
And it's tough.
They treat you different.
But you know, for me, I
just kind of stuck with it.
I'm like, this is what
I love, and it's not
about my gender or any
personal parts of who I am.
End of the day it's just
how dedicated you are
and how passionate you are
about what you're doing.
So I just kind of stayed
focused and ended up
working for Dominique Crenn,
which was the first female chef
that I worked for.
And that was an
amazing experience
to be able to have someone
that was getting recognized
in the industry at
that time, and to be
able to train with her.
So there was sort of this
role model, like wow,
she's doing it.
I can do this.
And I think times are changing.
Now you just see there is
more women representation
in the culinary world.
But again, I think we
just have to have a voice,
and we have to
continue to do speaking
panels and things like this, and
join together and be visible.
And that goes for
all parts of me.
I'm a woman of color.
I'm a female.
I'm part of the LGBTQ community.
I have all these sort
of minority categories
that I'm representing.
And yeah, I'm a chef,
but I think it gives me--
kind of puts me on
this level where
I can represent those
categories and be proud of that.
SPEAKER: That's great.
MELISSA KING: I ramble.
SPEAKER: No, no, no.
That's a great long answer.
I loved it.
So then from that, how did
you get on to "Top Chef"?
MELISSA KING: Man, I
was always like, oh, I'm
never going to apply
for one of these shows.
I don't want to do
competition television.
I just want to cook.
And many, many years
I was against it.
And I had friends and
family that are like,
you need to apply.
Like just try.
And so I think one of my friends
filled out an application,
and they put it on my desk.
They're like, you're
filling this out.
And it's like a
30-page application
to apply for "Top Chef."
and I was like, all right,
let's give it a try.
But it took me maybe two
years to actually complete
it and have the guts
to just submit it.
But then I turned it in,
and I didn't get a call back
for another two years.
And I just thought,
OK, at least I tried.
And I give myself
props for that.
And then they called
a few years later.
And I had to go through
the whole process again.
And it's like a three-month
back to back interviews.
And they're flying to LA and
you're interviewing there.
And next thing you know,
I was packing up my knives
and heading to Boston.
Like within a week, they tell
you, OK, you're on "Top Chef."
We're flying you out next week.
So it was an
incredible experience.
SPEAKER: Did you just
have to drop a lot just
to get out there and do it?
MELISSA KING: You do.
Yeah.
And I think it's one
of those things where
you have that opportunity.
And if you're going to go
for it, and they say yes,
you can't say no and just
back out all of a sudden.
So I was all right, let's do
it and see where this goes.
And I'll just try my best.
And yeah, it went well.
SPEAKER: So after
that, what doors
did that open with
that kind of coverage?
MELISSA KING: You know, it's
incredible what it can for--
if you really just--
I think a lot of people,
some come off the show
and then they just go
back to their normal jobs.
But it really does open
up a lot of opportunities.
Like right now I'm working with
companies like Humphrey Slocum.
You'll get to try
the ice cream later.
I actually did an event
yesterday with Williams-Sonoma,
and I'm a chef ambassador
for Whole Foods Market.
So like all these
other companies come
and they're like, hey, we
want to collaborate with you.
And that's, I think,
where my strengths lie
and where I want to be able
to work with these companies
to create something fun.
Even Google.
Hey, let's do something cool
here and make something.
So yeah, it definitely changes
your life, the whole "Top Chef"
experience, or can change
your life if you really
take advantage of it.
SPEAKER: When we talked
about this earlier,
you did mention that you
cook for some celebrities.
I'm just curious, when
you cook for celebrities,
do they want you to
cook stuff that they
saw you cook on "Top Chef"?
Or do they just tell you to go
wild and do whatever you want?
MELISSA KING: Usually
you just go wild, yeah,
do what you want.
It all came up because we were
in that-- what room was that?
SPEAKER: Broom
closet, the Speakeasy.
MELISSA KING: We were
in the broom closet.
Awesome room.
And he said that Al Gore
was here and did a talk.
SPEAKER: He did something.
MELISSA KING: He
did something and he
was hanging out in that room.
And I was like, oh, I
cooked for him before.
After "Top Chef" he, I
guess, had watched the show,
and it was like hey, I
want you to cook for me.
And he's a vegan.
And he let me do whatever
I wanted within those vegan
parameters.
And so I just did like a whole
10-course vegan tasting menu
for him and his friends.
So yeah, it's pretty cool.
They usually give
you a lot of freedom,
but within their
dietary restrictions.
SPEAKER: So with your
Co+Lab that you're doing,
which you maybe have to explain
to some of us what the Co+Lab
does.
But does that fit into this
freedom that you have as well?
MELISSA KING: Yeah.
Well, Co+Lab started
right after "Top Chef."
I was like, I want
to just feed people
and I want to do a cool dinner.
And so I came up with Co+Lab,
where I was collaborating with
other chefs in the city, and
also local artists and artisans
within the city, and products.
So we would take
those products--
for instance, we
had Philz Coffee,
we had Bellwether
Ricotta Cheese,
and we were just sourcing
from different purveyors
and really highlighting
those ingredients
within each course of the menu.
And so I was able to
take Co+Lab down to LA,
and I did dinner with
all the female "Top Chef"
finalists and winners.
So we had Mei Lin, we had Brooke
Williamson, Nyesha Arrington,
and Shirley Chung.
And that was an
awesome dinner where
we collaborated and came up
with this really fun menu
using local LA products.
And part of the proceeds
went to La Casina,
which is a women-run
organization up
in San Francisco.
So it was just great.
It was an opportunity for me to
be able to be creative and host
dinners in different areas.
SPEAKER: And you partner with--
it seems like you just have
friends everywhere, and
you'll partner with just--
you'll find a reason
to partner with them,
like, I'm doing this.
You make tables.
Come and--
MELISSA KING: Yeah.
For me, like I had a
friend that makes ceramics.
And I'm like, hey,
do you want to make
ceramics for my
pop-up dinner and make
it specific to that course?
So I think it's
just about community
and really working together to
put on a really amazing dinner
that you walk away
just feeling wow,
there was so much thought
put into every detail.
That's what Co+Lab was about.
SPEAKER: How'd that
turn into being
an ambassador at Whole Foods
and also creating your own ice
cream?
MELISSA KING: Yeah.
The Whole Foods thing came up.
I just kind of formed a
relationship with the company,
and next thing you
know I was creating
products for their hot bar.
And we were thinking,
how can we keep
making things interesting
within the market place?
So I was like, why don't
we make an ice cream?
So we reached out
to Humphrey Slocum,
which was one of my favorites
because they come up
with crazy flavor profiles.
And next thing you
know, all three of us
just started brainstorming, how
can we make a fun of ice cream?
So we came up with
Hong Kong Milk Tea ice
cream, which was inspired
by my childhood and just
my cultural background.
My family's from Hong Kong,
and we drank Hong Kong milk tea
all the time.
For those of you that
don't know what it is,
it's a black tea that you
brew really, really strong.
And you mix condensed
milk in there.
And sometimes people put
a little evaporated milk
or sugar.
But it's kind of creamy, has
a lot of tannins from the tea.
And we turned that into an ice
cream base with Strauss milk.
And then we're like,
OK, this needs texture.
So we decided to make almond
cookies and folded that in.
So you'll get to
try that in a bit.
But it's kind of this play on
tea and shortbread cookies.
SPEAKER: So you
got the inspiration
from growing up with that.
Where else do you
draw inspiration
from with all these pop-ups?
MELISSA KING: I
think a lot of it
actually comes from my childhood
or just places I've traveled.
I traveled a lot when I was
young, and throughout my 20s
I backpacked Asia a few times,
and Europe in between jobs.
Yeah, I think just
from there, just
being able to explore and
taste all these unique flavors
from other areas of the world.
And I'm like, how can
I bring those flavors
here into the form of
the cooking that I do?
And so that's kind of, I
guess, where my inspiration
comes from.
But also nature
is a big one, too.
I like to be outdoors.
And I think that comes in
my plating style sometimes.
When you see some of my dishes,
or more my fine dining dishes
are inspired by nature
and gardens and stuff.
Try to make it look
organic, you know?
SPEAKER: Do you try to keep
it very localized ideas
with the plating and that?
MELISSA KING: Absolutely.
Yeah.
I'm always in my
backyard foraging,
always trying to get to
know friends that hunt
and fish because I think it's
important to support that.
And for me it's
about the quality.
You can taste the quality
of the ingredients
when you're getting it straight
from the source versus having
it travel miles to get to you.
So yeah, I think
for me, I really
try to support local
as much as possible.
And you know, these people
are working so hard.
A lot of these small
mom and pop businesses,
they're working so
hard, and I want
to support that rather
than the man sometimes.
SPEAKER: With all that
you're doing now, how big
is your social media presence?
Do you have somebody
else taking care of that,
or how important is it?
MELISSA KING: No, I do my own.
It's more authentic that way.
And I like to share
what I'm doing.
I think I was downstairs taking
a picture of the Google sign,
saying, I'm here.
So yeah, I definitely
run my own accounts.
And I think it's important
to just connect to people.
But yes, social media does
play a very big role these days
in your brand and
the exposure of that.
And when I was hosting my
first Co+Lab, I was like,
how am I going to
sell tickets to this?
So I just started blasting it
on Instagram, and it works.
It's really amazing,
the power of it.
SPEAKER: So how do we
find you on Instagram?
Do we just search your name?
MELISSA KING: Yeah,
just Chef Melissa King.
I think all my handles
are @ChefMelissaKing,
or ChefMelissaKing.com.
You can actually email
me straightforward.
It goes right to me, and I think
that's how you guys found me.
So if you do enough
stalking, you can find me.
SPEAKER: Follow me around the
city to find your Co+Labs.
MELISSA KING: Yeah,
show up at my house.
SPEAKER: What advice
can you give those
who are aspiring to be a chef?
MELISSA KING: You
know, if you've never
cooked in a
professional kitchen,
make sure you do
that first before you
go to culinary school.
A lot of people come out,
they watch things on TV
and they're like, oh,
I want to be a chef.
That must be fun.
And it is.
It's a lot of fun, but at the
same time it's so much work.
And it's not an easy life.
And I think do your research.
Make sure you go get an
internship at a restaurant,
and really just get your--
work there for free if
you have to because that's
how my industry works.
And dedicate that
time to really see
if this is something
you want to dedicate
your life to because,
again, you're working
every weekend, every holiday.
You can't go home
and feed your kids.
It's tough to
balance that, having
a family and your career.
And I'm sure that applies
to a lot of industries,
just having to balance it all.
SPEAKER: Some days you
just go into work feeling
like it's going
to be a war zone.
MELISSA KING: It's a war
zone every day in a kitchen.
I can guarantee you that one.
Something always goes wrong.
SPEAKER: Well, I don't think
I have any more questions,
actually.
But we do have a lot
of people here who
I know have lots of questions.
Let me grab a microphone.
MELISSA KING: Yeah.
Shoot away.
Any questions.
All right, there.
AUDIENCE: Hi there.
Thanks for coming.
What's your favorite
restaurant in San Francisco?
MELISSA KING: That's
a hard question.
There's a lot that I frequent.
I think it depends on what
type of food I'm looking for.
But I feel like I
go to Rintaro a lot.
It's a Japanese izakaya over
by Rainbow Grocery Store
in the Mission.
That one's great.
I flew to Japan a lot
last year because I
was opening a restaurant project
called El Cafe out there.
And when I go eat
at Rintaro, it just
reminds me of really homey
Japanese comfort foods.
It's like homemade
udon and katsu.
Nothing too fancy, but
they do a great job there.
Couple other places.
I've been really
into RT Rotisserie.
Have you guys been there?
It's a fun, simple
spot, but they just
do a really awesome
roast chicken
with Douglas Fir yogurt sauce
and different dipping sauces.
And they do these umami
fries that are amazing.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
what was it called?
MELISSA KING: RT Rotisserie.
It's from the people
that did Rich Table,
and it's their more
fast casual concept.
But I think San
Francisco, that's
kind of what we're
moving towards,
is what can we eat
that's done well, made
with good ingredients,
and is quick,
and that we can sit
there and still get
a beer or a glass of wine?
So you see RT
Rotisserie popping up,
and places like Souvla where
it's really quick to just get
in and out.
SPEAKER: I'm going
to sneak across.
AUDIENCE: I'm
curious your thoughts
on the sort of upswell of
fast casual restaurants.
There's a lot of
art to fine dining.
And I think we certainly
see some art in fast casual.
But I'm curious your
thoughts on this.
We definitely see
it in San Francisco
and I'd love to
hear more from you.
MELISSA KING: Absolutely.
Yeah, you know, part
of me is a little sad
that fine dining is
dying because that
was where I came
from and the kitchens
that I've been bred through.
Yeah, it is an
art, like you said.
And I think right
now, definitely times
are changing because
people want convenience
and they want affordability.
But I think there's a way to
bridge that and still make
that food elevated and
delicious and technique-driven
without having to cost a lot for
the owner and for the customer
as well.
But yeah, I do think--
a little part of me is sad.
AUDIENCE: He laughs as he
hands me the microphone.
So my question is
actually kind of random.
After "Top Chef,"
people obviously
started recognizing you and
following you on social media.
Were you involved with social
media before as a normal Person
MELISSA KING: I
definitely had Instagram.
AUDIENCE: How did that
change for you after,
when you realized
like, oh, weird.
Now there's all these
people who think that they
know me and are following me.
And now I'm sending
a message and I'm
representing all these things.
Did you feel you needed
to post different content
or curate it more or anything?
MELISSA KING: Yeah.
I definitely think--
I had Instagram before
and only had, maybe,
like 100 followers,
or just my friends.
And then overnight
it really does change
when you go on a TV show.
Suddenly you're getting
like 100 followers a day.
And I think from there,
I started realizing, oh,
what I'm putting out
there people are really
taking serious.
And I have to either be sure
I'm censoring certain things,
or kind of curate
it a little more.
So yeah, I think just being
aware of what I'm putting out
there and the message
that's coming across
is something that
I constantly am,
what do I Instagram today,
because it's a lot of pressure,
you know?
But it's become a full time job
sometimes to keep up with that.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
I asked because a couple
weeks or months ago, I
was involved in a
Women in and Twitter--
I wrote a Tweet
and had the hashtag
that was part of this
Women and Tech movement.
And mine became the top
Tweet of the movement,
which became the top tag on
Twitter for an entire weekend.
And so I went through
this experience
where all of a sudden
my phone was just
constant notifications.
The Tweet got over
a million hits.
Like actually, M as in million.
And I was like, I am
just a software engineer.
And then I had this
paralysis every time
I went to post something.
It was like, they're expecting
something from me now.
And I'm just a girl who
had a really good crepe
and I just wanted to
share a picture of it.
MELISSA KING: Usually I do that.
Yeah, usually I'm like, I
just ate this amazing meal
and I want to share
it with the world.
But then there's
also other messages
that I want to explain
to people, where
if I'm involved in a pride
parade for the LGBT community,
I want to share that
and continue to spread
that voice as much as I can.
So yeah, I think there
are parts of my brain
that are, OK, is
this OK to post?
Is it OK to just
post my sandwich
that I just had at Google?
Is anyone going to care?
But yeah, it's fun.
AUDIENCE: I just wanted
to ask, so as a woman,
do you feel like that
has held you back,
or that's held you from
succeeding in your life,
and there was a pivotal moment
in the culinary industry?
I guess I should
be more specific.
MELISSA KING: I don't
think it's held me back.
But I have had
experiences in kitchens
where I was treated different.
You know, I was working in a
place where one of my chefs
is a very traditional
Japanese guy from Japan.
And I think the
experience was like, oh,
are you sure you want to
do this with your life?
And I was like,
what do you mean?
I'm just like the other guys.
And he's like, well,
I mean cooking.
Like you can't have a family.
And he was questioning me.
And I was like,
well, I don't think
that you have to
completely sacrifice that.
Of course, you can make
compromises and accommodations
with your partner.
But I think he just felt--
I don't know, somehow I
was treated differently
in that scenario
for being a woman.
He wouldn't have asked
the men that question.
Are you sure you
want to be a chef?
What about your family?
So I guess we
always constantly--
people will approach us
with questions like that.
But it's good to think about it.
But I still think it doesn't
matter what your gender is.
And if you are good
at what you're doing
and you're dedicated,
then you will succeed.
And a lot of it, again, is just
joining together and continuing
to participate in
speaking panels,
or continuing to spread that
voice for the female community.
Yeah.
SPEAKER: Do we have
any more questions
before we have some ice cream?
Nope?
We got one right here.
Of course you may.
AUDIENCE: I mean, you're here.
I'd love to take
advantage of this.
So you're working
with Whole Foods,
and now you're working
with Humphrey Slocum,
and that's such a great
partnership or tri-ship.
I don't know what you would
call the three together.
What are you next
most excited about?
MELISSA KING: I definitely
have a few projects
that I've been working
on that I can't tell you
right now what's going on.
But I will be back
to tell you more.
But hopefully it's something big
and exciting that you'll see.
It's definitely
restaurant-focused.
And also I have so many things
on my list that I want to do.
And it's like, OK, which one
am I going to knock off first?
And just focusing
towards restaurant,
check, cookbook, check,
those sort of things.
So there's definitely a few.
But within my
current schedule, I
have a few events that
I'll be participating in.
One is called Girl Venture.
And it's a organization
here in the Mission
at the Women's Center.
And they support women,
the youth community,
just to help empower them.
They go rock climbing,
they go kayaking,
and they do a lot of
outdoor activities
to help these young girls
really feel supported.
So I'm going to be hosting their
gala dinner on September 21.
I think we still have
tickets available
if anybody wants to come.
And I'll be at the Newport
Beach Wine and Food Festival
at the end of the month.
And a couple other
Top Chefers are there.
And that'll be fun, and that
one's with Whole Foods Market.
Yeah, a lot of fun
events lined up.
AUDIENCE: Can I ask
one more question?
It just occurred to me we're
about to try some delicious ice
cream.
Can you tell us
a little bit more
about ice cream development,
like how many different types
did you try?
MELISSA KING: This
particular ice cream
we figured out very
quickly, surprisingly.
We went through about
four different batches
and met up four different
times to do taste tests.
But I basically made a
batch of tea and was,
this is what it
needs to taste like.
And from there, I was with
the chefs at Humphrey Slocum.
His name is Jake.
Jake and Sean are the
owners of Humphrey Slocum,
and we kind of met up together
and were brainstorming like,
OK, is this too sweet?
If it is, maybe we should cut
back on the condensed milk.
But we tweaked it
out really quickly.
And hopefully you
guys enjoy it today.
And it's sold exclusively
at Whole Foods
Market in a little pint.
Hopefully it will spread
down to different regions
of Whole Foods.
Currently it's only in the
northern California districts.
AUDIENCE: Thanks for coming.
Not to stand between
everyone and ice cream.
So curious about "Top Chef."
What were the big
things that you
learned about your cooking
style, about yourself?
What you learn from others there
that kind of surprised you?
MELISSA KING: Yeah.
I think for my cooking,
it really opened me up.
I mean, it opened me
up in so many ways.
As a person, I was very shy.
There's no way I would
do something like this.
I can't even give a wedding
speech at my sister's wedding.
But I was just very shy.
And definitely opened up my
confidence in my cooking,
in me as a person,
and also in just
where I wanted to go with
the future of my career.
And so I think I
learned a lot there.
It also taught me to just
be spontaneous with cooking
and don't be afraid
to experiment.
And a lot of the show
was just improvising
because you know,
you literally have
30 minutes to cook something,
so you're oh no, what am
I supposed to make right now?
So you're just throwing
things in a pot.
And everything we
made on that show,
I would say for every chef, they
would probably tell you they've
never made it
before in real life.
It was the first time every
time with those recipes.
So definitely learning to
improvise was a big thing.
And then they surprised me
with my mom on the show.
And that was the most
incredible feeling.
And you know, you're there and
it's so serious and stressful.
And the whole time you're
just in competition mode.
And then all of a sudden
your mom shows up.
So I just broke down
in tears, and it really
made me feel like I have
these people that support me.
And when you're in
the competition,
you don't feel any of that.
You're so just separate.
So I came home just realizing
how much I appreciate
my family and my friends.
AUDIENCE: And to add
to that question,
obviously we only see
a sliver of what you've
experienced on "Top Chef."
So are there any misperceptions
from being in your shoes,
being on the show versus
what you actually see on TV?
MELISSA KING: There's definitely
creative editing is probably
as far as I could say.
But I don't know.
I've seen every
episode, and I felt
it was very true to
everyone's characters.
It might be a little
dramatized on certain episodes.
But yeah, imagine you're filming
every day, 16 hours a day,
maybe 18.
And you're only seeing
about 45 minutes of that.
So it's all condensed in there.
Yeah, they definitely
get creative.
I was, wait, did that happen?
Like mixing things around.
Any other questions?
Cooking tips or anything
you guys want to know?
AUDIENCE: Yeah,
throw 'em out there.
MELISSA KING:
Yeah, I don't know.
Ask me something.
Again, I think just
experiment more.
If there's ingredients out
there that you've never seen,
go buy it and taste it
and try to cook with it.
And you know, recipes
are guidelines.
You don't have to follow
every little detail.
I think it's OK
to veer from that,
and if you don't like a
particular ingredient,
omit it and try something
else that you do like.
And there it will evolve into
its own dish that you created.
So yeah, cooking should be fun.
AUDIENCE: So I recently
started cooking a lot more.
Before my husband actually
did 90% of the cooking.
And once I started cooking more,
he says he loves me more too.
But I use Instant Pot,
and I was wondering
if you have Instant
Pot, and if so,
if you have any favorite
Instant Pot recipes.
MELISSA KING: I do
not have Instant Pot.
My sister does,
and she loves it.
And she's a mom with twins
and she works at Disney,
and so her life is crazy.
But yeah, the Instant
Pot is basically
like a pressure cooker
and a slow cooker,
from my understanding.
She's always doing those
Nom Nom paleo recipes, which
are from my friend Michelle.
And she actually just
came out with a cookbook.
But yeah, she's got
great recipes there
that are really simple.
They are paleo-focused.
But you can always add
your own things to that.
AUDIENCE: Any favorite quick
weeknight dinner recipes
that are not Instant Pot?
MELISSA KING: Let me see here.
Oh, well, my Lemon
Grass Meatball recipe.
I think you guys are
going to try that later.
That one is
something that I have
on the Whole Foods hot bar,
and it's a really easy recipe.
I have it on my website,
ChefMelissaKing.com.
At least I think I
have it on my website.
And it takes about 25 minutes,
and you just marinate the meat.
And you don't even have to
form them into meatballs.
You can make a burger
patty with it and grill it.
But it's got fish sauce,
garlic, ginger, lemon grass,
all these really yummy flavors.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
SPEAKER: You're welcome.
While I'm walking over
here, what are you
watching on Netflix right now?
MELISSA KING: I know.
Well, now that "Game of
Thrones" is over, which I love,
I've been watching "Insecure,"
which I love as well.
I don't know, what's
out there these days.
I feel like after "Game of
Thrones," there's nothing else.
AUDIENCE: This is
kind of random.
What's your go to cooking
utensil or certain pot
or pan that's out there?
I know some people are
really into cast iron.
MELISSA KING: I was
just about to say that.
I'm all about everyone
should have a cast iron pan.
It's like $20, or you
can go to a flea market
and get it for
probably even cheaper.
They last forever,
and if you're going
to just make a steak at home,
it conducts heat way better
than any other pan.
And so you'll get a really
nice crust on your steak
if you cook with that.
But I cook everything in it,
like fried eggs and fried rice
and stuff like that.
So yeah, definitely
get a cast iron.
Microplanes are
pretty handy as well.
It's like a little grater that
grates ginger and lemon zest
and stuff like that.
All right.
Cool.
SPEAKER: Time for
some ice cream?
MELISSA KING: Yeah.
I know.
Do you guys want some ice cream?
Ready for that?
All right.
Well, thank you guys.
SPEAKER: Thank you so much.
Thank you for this.
This was a lot of fun.
[APPLAUSE]